vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir le burkina
faso continue son bras de fer avec la
cedeao sur la durée de la transition et
la libération du président déchu roch
marc christian kaboré toujours des plus
de culot coup d'état du mois de janvier
dernier
un nouveau front qui fait rage dans
l'est du tigre et en ethiopie alors que
la situation semblait s'être apaisées
ces derniers mois des centaines de
milliers de personnes déplacées
reportage à suivre dans la région d'afar
le tirage au sort de la coupe du monde
ait connue nous analysons les chances
des cinq équipes africaines qualifiées
avec notre spécialiste des sports benoît
et rochers restez avec nous
on ouvre ce journal par le bras de fer
qui oppose la junte au pouvoir au
burkina faso et la cedeao l'instant sous
régionale avait sommé les militaires au
pouvoir de présenter un nouveau
chronogramme de moins de 3 ans et de
libérer le président déchu roch marc
christian kaboré qui est toujours
assigné à résidence depuis le 25 janvier
dernier écoutez l'analyse d'abdoulaye
barry doctorant à l'université pour la
paix une institution académique de l'onu
et nous expliquer la stratégie de la
junte face à la cedeao concernant
notamment le chronogramme pour un retour
à la démocratie on écoute dont mais
toutes deux disposent d'un tiers du
point
il y à un furet qui laisse entrevoir
donc l'éventuelle bras de fer entre le
burkina faso et la cedeao la cedeao qui
demandent donc au burkina de souvenirs
donc un programme avec un délai
raisonnable des élections mais la
réalité est tout autre chose est le
programme pour l'instant n'est pas dans
un bras de fer avec la cedeao loin lui
l'art lorsqu'on échanges avec les
autorités doivent être courts des
diplomates et des sources proches de la
présidence leur genre du burkina du
gouvernement burkinabè serre et donc de
négocier pour avoir un accompagnement de
la cedeao parce que je vous le dis la
situation pour qui la mer est assez
complexe avec une crise
multidimensionnelle pour vous dire
clairement que le burkina ne pourra pas
faire face donc à aiguille à des
sanctions économiques et financières
pour le moment on n'en est pas là
évidemment lors du dernier souper la cda
ouattara
les dirigeants de l'organisation
sous-régionale en inde y met donc à
ouagadougou de fixer les délais
raisonnables et passer la barre des 5 ap
d'échangés promis qu'il financière s'est
encore engagé automatiquement mais pour
l'instant on n'en est pas là le
président la commission massives yahoo
est arrivé cet après midi à ouagadougou
il est en ce moment nous devancent avec
le preneur damiba président de la
transition il est accompagné avec des
experts classique eaux et de l'air avec
le bruit selon un entretien destine
séance de travail donc avec les
autorités pour qu'ils n'avaient et on
espère qu'à la fin de cet impôt on aura
pour avoir un consensus
le chef d'état major des forces armées
françaises était de passage à niamey
pour une nouvelle rencontre avec son
homologue nigérien il s'est rendu dans
le nord de la région de tillabéri près
de la ville de ouallam à moins de 100 km
de la frontière malienne où les
affrontements continuent d'imposer une
pression sur cette partie du niger les
précisions de notre correspondant à
niamey harold gira
c'est la troisième visite du chef d'état
major des armées français ici au niger
des visites qu'ils multiplient et jeudi
il a voulu afficher la confiance qu'il
porte à la cohésion entre l'armée
française et l'armée nigérienne du côté
français ce qu'on essaye d'éviter c'est
un scénario qui ressemblerait à celui du
mali est justement une rupture de
confiance le mali qui reste au centre de
toutes les discussions ici au niger car
l'état islamique au grand sahara et les
groupes signataires des accords de paix
de 2015 continuent de s'affronter dans
la zone la plus proche de la frontière
nord de la région de tillabéri thierry
burkhard lui veut rester prudent quant à
l'avenir des troupes françaises censés a
quitté le mali la vocation des unités
françaises au mali qui sur des blocs ne
sont pas forcément devenir au niger ça
veut pas dire qu'il ya pas d une pièce
française qui sont au mali qui ne
viendront pas au niger si les autorités
nigériennes le demander que ça
corresponde à un besoin et une
efficacité militaire c'est quelque chose
qui sera étudiée mais il faut pas
inverser c'est bien ce que demanderont
les autorités nigériennes qui pourrait
être mis en place ici et pas
unités françaises qui sont au mali qui
viendront déjà c'est pas comme ça que ça
pouvait résumer le chef d'état major
affirme que c'est environ 900 militaires
français qui sont actuellement basés au
niger un soutien essentiellement assuré
par voie aérienne mais pour l'instant
pas de grandes précisions sur
l'évolution du partenariat militaire
entre les deux pays
en république démocratique du congo le
groupe rebelle m23 a déclaré un cessez
le feu unilatéral dans l'est du pays une
déclaration qui intervient après
plusieurs jours de combats avec l'armée
congolaise
le groupe dit rechercher un dialogue
avec le gouvernement aucun commentaire
pour l'instant n'a été fait les
autorités congolaises
on passe à l'ethiopie ou le conflit dans
le nord du pays semblait s'être apaisées
ces derniers mois mais dans la région
d'afar l'est du tigre et un nouveau
front fait rage des centaines de
milliers de personnes ont été déplacées
et de nombreuses familles séparées
reportage de notre correspondante maria
guers nicolescu
dans ce village situé à 25 km de la
ligne de front idriss mohamed a entraîné
près de 400 miliciens à fars aujourd'hui
la plupart d'entre eux sont partis se
battre dans les montagnes de leur région
contre les forces du tigré voisins
nos milices se bat uniquement avec des
kalachnikov les ennemis eux ont de
l'artillerie lourde
l'armée gouvernementale ne participent
pas aux combats ce sont uniquement les
milices et les forces spéciales afar qui
se battent il ya beaucoup de morts et de
blessés mais le nombre de victimes reste
inconnu certains morts n'ont pas encore
été enterré chaque jour de nouveaux
blessés civils et militaires arrivent
depuis les zones de combat signe que les
hostilités se poursuivent
contrairement aux déclarations du tplf
et du gouvernement fédéral
j'étais prêt de cauna baha mar oui nous
ont attaqués par les deux côtés on a été
encerclé par deux unités nous on n'est
pas allé dans leur région c'est eux qui
nous ont attaqués chez nous ce sont des
ennemis avant la guerre on était amis on
se respectait comme des voisins nous
partageons une longue frontière donc
nous nous respections beaucoup
l'objectif de l'offensive lancée par les
tigres et en contre la région afar en
janvier restent floues une hypothèse
serait que les forces tigréenne
souhaiterait rejoindre l'autoroute
reliant addis abeba au port de djibouti
pour ouvrir un canal d'approvisionnement
vers le tigré mais les attaques
viseraient aussi de nombreuses
habitations civiles et plus de 300 mille
personnes ont fui leurs villages
patoux mali a marché pendant un mois
avec ses huit enfants
je suis venu de la ville d'aba là on est
descendu depuis les montagnes en
marchant sur des pierres au marché puis
on se reposer et ont recommencé à
marcher certains disaient que les tigres
et un était derrière nous et qu'il
fallait courir et beaucoup de personnes
sont tombées dans la montagne seize mois
après le début de la guerre dans le nord
de l'ethiopie les crises humanitaires
continuent à se multiplier y compris
dans la région du tigré mais aucun
journaliste n'a été autorisé à s'y
rendre depuis neuf mois
on passe au football pour aborder la
prochaine coupe du monde au qatar le
tirage au sort a lieu ce vendredi et
notre chroniqueur benoît perreault chez
nous a parlé des chances des cinq
équipes africaines qualifiées on écoute
la deuxième la confédération la plus
représentée en coupe du monde derrière
l'europe et ses 13 qualifiés alors est
ce qu ils ont été chanceux ou pas ces
pays africains regardent et le sénégal
récent champion d'afrique les lions de
la teranga ont les ressources pour se
qualifier et sortir de ce groupe à qui
comporte le pays hôte le qatar les
pays-bas et l'équateur qatar équateur ce
sera d'ailleurs le match d'ouverture de
cette coupe du monde le 21 novembre
prochain puisque oui c'est du monde ne
se déroulera pas en été mais à l'automne
le sénégal débutera sa compétition face
aux pays-bas le même jour avant
d'affronter le qatar le 25 et finir face
aux équatoriens ça sera compliqué pour
les qatari dans ce groupe seul pays hôte
à ne pas avoir franchi ce premier tour
jusque là l'afrique du sud en 2010 le
qatar tentera de ne pas les imiter la
tunisie elle atterrit dans le groupe des
bleus ces deux pays qui ne se sont
jamais affrontées en coupe du monde ce
sera forcément un match très particulier
pour la forte diaspora tunisienne qui
vit en france les aigles de carthage qui
ont atteint les quarts de finale de la
dernière coupe d'afrique des nations ils
affronteront donc les champions du monde
en titre le temps 30 novembre débuteront
face au au danemark avant de disputer
leur deuxième match face au vainqueur du
barrage intercontinental 1 le pérou
l'australie ou les émirats arabes unis
et alors le maroc qui est dans le groupe
f avec la belgique le canada et la
croatie se sera pas facile pour les
hommes de vahid halilhozdic face au
dernier finaliste et les diables rouges
emmenés par eden hazard kevin de bruyne
une seule confrontation en coupe du
monde entre la belgique et le maroc
c'était en 1994 et les marocains
s'étaient imposés s'était incliné par
dont 1 0 le cameroun de value en
découdre avec le brésil la suisse et la
serbie une deuxième place derrière le
brésil qui la première place semble
promise est tout à fait jouable pour les
lions indomptables qui ont terminé
troisièmes de leur canne en février
dernier puis enfin dernier pays
africains concernés par cette ce tirage
au sort le ghana très décevant au
cameroun en janvier éliminé dès la phase
de groupes affrontera le portugal de
cristiano ronaldo l'uruguay edinson
cavani et la corée du sud c'est ainsi
que nous refermons ce journal l'afrique
merci à tous ceux qui nous ont suivis de
niamey à ouagadougou en passant par
libreville restez avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]